salut brut c'est manon j'ai 22 ans et il
ya deux ans je suis allé à l'hôpital
pour défendre douleurs au ventre et j'ai
appris que sans le savoir j'étais maman
et que j'allais accoucher quelques
heures après j'ai mis au monde ruben
qu'à deux ans et qui est la prunelle de
mes yeux aujourd'hui
99 il est 3 heures du matin je sens
quelque chose en fait qui me réveille et
je sens directement qu'en fait j'ai
mouillé complètement tout mon lit une
douleur qui a réparé dans les mêmes
pacem même pas 30 secondes après une
douleur dans le dos dans les reins donc
automatiquement ont fait le
rapprochement pense directement aux
reins aux calculs haut-rhin quand je me
suis fait pitié tout ça pour moi c'était
impossible de réveiller mes parents pour
quelque chose comme ça je pense qu'en
fait c'est c'est le déni qui continuent
à ce moment là et qui se dit qui dit non
non mais c'est rien c'est rien c'est une
sensation qui part des reins et qui
descend vers le vent donc je pense qu'en
fait il était tout simplement en train
de se placer c'est ce qu'ils m'ont dit
les infirmières qu'il est en train de se
placer vers déjà yann mais on est parti
on est parti à l'hôpital la sage femme
est arrivée avec deux infirmières et
elle a commencé à me poser des questions
tout ça ma dernière relation j'explique
machin est ce que j'ai bien mes
mensurations bien correctement bien
calés je lui dis oui prenez en main je
prenais mon moyen de contraception
normalement il n'ya pas de j'avais
patron c'était normalement et là je me
souviendrai toute ma vie et m'a regardé
et m'a dit et elle m'a dit je pense que
je pense que vous êtes enceinte j'ai une
sorte de génie sur deux trous noirs
géants fin je sais que j'ai bugué je la
seule chose c'est que mon regard s'est
tourné vers ma mère qui s'est mis tout
de suite à pleurer et à la première
chose qu'elle a dit aussi c'est bon dans
combien de temps il reste combien de
mois il reste en même temps et elle a
regardé la dénommée la madame en fait
vous n'avez pas compris la en fait elle
est dilatée à 3 mm
dans quelques heures a va accoucher dans
quelques heures
voilà votre petit votre petite fille
votre petit garçon va sortir c'est mon
ventre à huit mois et demi là on n'a pas
l'impression que j'ai tout que j'étais
enceinte un d une grossesse on dit que
le bébé se place juste à côté de la
colonne sur la colonne complètement
fermée recours ouvriers en pâture lui et
il se place là pour ceux se cacher au
maximum donc ça c'est la toute première
photo ça s'est même pas voyez la
turbulette les amis tout ça c'est pas à
moi c'est l'hôpital ça c'est ma toute
première vidéo là ce que je ressentais
cessé de la protection envers lui
j'avais un sentiment de culpabilité sur
le fait que je ne n'ai pas protégé
pendant neuf mois que j'ai peut-être
arrivé quelque chose à cause de moi à
cause de ce que je faisais c'est
peut-être ma faute si je l'ait pas vu
non plus ce soir là à ce moment là je me
posais trop de questions sur moi sur mon
corps pourquoi pourquoi je l'avais pas
vu pourquoi je suis pas comme les autres
sincèrement je pensais que j'avais un
problème en moi je fume je buvais
j'avais tous les week-ends pendant sept
mois dans les mains des clubs tout ça
donc forcément même j'avais en voyage
s'ils sont plus je profitais forcément
dans ces voyages là donc niveau nouveau
tout ça j'avais peur pour lui et pour
moi aussi parce que c'est provoquer
quelque chose sauf que les médecins
m'ont rassuré de suite et m'ont dit que
un bébé d une grossesse à se protéger
lui-même ça se fait une bouffe une boule
de protection et riil et tout ce qui est
mauvais pour lui il va pas l'accepter
comme j'ai accouché j'ai un suivi
psychologique quand même qui a été
obligatoire on m'a dit que quand d une
grossesse ça peut arriver à n'importe
quel âge n'importe quel moment
finalement c'est psychologique c'est
uniquement psychologique je me suis posé
la question forcément de regarder sur le
moment ou non c'est logique je pense
assure ça a duré quoi ça dure et 3,4
secondes mais c'est au moment où on se
croit incapable en fait on se dit mais
j'ai été incapable de loire alors
comment je suis capable de pouvoir
l'assumer et le pouvoir le gérer jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie à ça me permet
aujourd'hui d'en parler d'eux de faire
connaître des grossesses et dire qu'on
est parfois look on ne fait pas des
enfants dans le dos mais je regretterai
jamais ça c'est sûr et certain je
regretterai jamais d'avoir pris cette
décision la plus belle de ma vie
[Musique]